.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HAPPY GLORIOUS
TUESDAY, EVERYONE.
THINGS ARE GOING GREAT AROUND
HERE, ITS DATE 2 OF OUR AMAZING
HALLOWEEN EXTRAVAGANZA.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE NEWS, THE
NEXT EPISODE OF OUR FAVORITE
SITCOM AWAITS.
♪ ♪
>> TONIGHT'S EPISODE, INSIDE THE
WRITERS ROOM.
>> I WAS THINKING, THE SHOW IS
NOT AS FUNNY AS IT USED TO BE,
WE COULD USE MORE LAUGHS.
ANYONE ELSE AGREE?
>> I THINK THE SHOW IS AS FUNNY
AS IT'S EVER BEEN, IF ANYTHING
THERE'S TOO MANY LAUGHS.
RIGHT.
FREE FRUIT.
>> FOX & FRIENDS CALLED,
APPARENTLY SOMEONE MURDERED
BRIAN KILMEADE AND HUNG HIS BODY
UPSIDE DOWN IN
AINSLEY EARHARDT'S OFFICE.
WE HAVE A FEELING FOR HIM.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: APPLAUDING DEATH, I
ALWAYS LOVE A HAPPY ENDING.
HAVE YOU NOTICED HOW GREAT
THINGS ARE GOING IN AMERICA?
ANOTHER MASSIVE CARAVAN COMING
OUR WAY SURGING PAST MEXICAN
FORCES, AND SURGING PAST MEXICO
IN GENERAL.
I FEEL BAD FOR MEXICO.
I IMAGINE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
APPARENTLY ESCAPING A OF
DESPERATION AND THEY ENTER YOUR
COUNTRY AND TO SAY NO THANKS,
WE'LL KEEP GOING.
MEXICO MUST FEEL LIKE EVERYONE'S
FIRST WIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS RUDE TO.
IT'S LIKE ASKING THE MAITRE D'
OF A RESTAURANT DIRECTIONS TO
ANOTHER RESTAURANT.
IT'S LIKE GOING UP TO THE
HOSTESS AT APPLEBEE'S AND SAYING
EXCUSE ME, DO YOU KNOW A PLACE
THAT OFFERS MAINSTREAM AMERICAN
DISHES SERVED IN A CASUAL DINING
ATMOSPHERE, THAT OFFERS
DELICIOUS APPETIZERS AND NO, NOT
YOU.
THAT'S MEXICO.
EVERYONE WALKING RIGHT ON
THROUGH LIKE IT'S THE HOSIERY
DEPARTMENT AT MACY'S.
HIM YOU ALWAYS HAD TO GO THROUGH
THERE TO GET TO SOMEPLACE GOOD
TO.
IT'S MORE DEMORALIZING THAN NOT
GETTING A ROSE ON THE BACHELOR,
JUST ASK CAT.
WE DON'T JUST HAVE INFLATION, WE
HAVE HYPERINFLATION.
I ASKED LARRY KUDLOW WHAT IT WAS
AND HE SAID IT'S INFLATION BUT
HYPER.
[LAUGHTER]
AND HE PUNCHED ME IN THE FACE.
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW HE ROLLS.
WE'VE COVERED THE RISING CRIME
RATES ALREADY, THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS CONTINUE TO MAKE LIFE AND
THERE IS THIS.
>> LOS ANGELES AND -- WHAT AM I
DOING HERE?
[APPLAUSE]
THERE'S TWO FAMOUS GUYS IN THIS
AUDIENCE HERE.
>> THE FORMER GENERAL, KEEP
CALLING HIM GENERAL.
>> VISIT VACCINES.COM, OR TEXT
YOUR ZIP CODE TO 438829.
>> TWO WEEKS, OR A WEEK?
I'M LOSING TRACK OF TIME.
>> Greg: THAT INSTILLS
CONFIDENCE BUT IT RAISES THE
QUESTION, HOW CAN HE BE LOST IN
THOUGHT WHEN YOU HAVE NO
THOUGHTS?
WE ARE IN WORSE SHAPE THAN
STELTER AFTER THE HOLIDAYS.
THAT YOU KNOW HIS ASTROLOGICAL
SIGN IS EGGNOG?
WHAT ARE OUR LEADERS FOCUSING ON
RIGHT NOW?
TERRIBLE.
LAST FRIDAY THE WHITE HOUSE
RELEASED A 42 PAGE PLAN TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS.
MY KID, IT'S TO PROMOTE GENDER
EQUALITY BECAUSE THAT'S THE
URGENT PROBLEM.
NOT JUST AT HOME, BUT ABROAD.
YEAH, A BROAD.
THAT'S FUNNY, A SEXIST WOULD
SAY.
NEVER MIND THE HYPERINFLATION
AND OPEN BORDER AT HOME, IS A
HOSTESS MAKING $0.03 LESS THAN
HER MALE COUNTERPART, THANKFULLY
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN TELLING THE
TALIBAN TO HIRE MORE WOMEN.
APPARENTLY THIS IS A REMEDY OF
AN EQUAL PLAYING FIELD, ONE THAT
HAS BEEN WORSENED BY COVID.
WHICH IS SUCH B.S., THE SMELL OF
IT SHOULD BE SEEPING OUT OF YOUR
TV.
YOU WANT TO TALK COVID
INEQUALITY?
THE GLOBAL DEATH RATE FOR MEN IS
ABOUT 15% HIGHER THAN WOMEN, IF
THAT STATISTIC WERE REVERSED,
THERE WOULD BE MARCHES AND THEY
WOULD BE THE KIND OF MARCHES
THAT THE MEDIA WOULD SAY DON'T
SPREAD COVID.
THAT MEANS FOR EVERY TEN WOMEN,
THERE 15 MEN WHO CROAK.
UNLIKE ME, GENDER EQUALITY ONLY
GOES ONE WAY.
IF YOU'RE A WOMAN WHO DISAGREES,
TRY REGISTERING FOR THE DRAFT.
NEVER MIND INDUSTRIAL ACCIDENTS
AND FATALITIES, THE RAVAGES OF
WAR, MEN OFTEN GET THE SHORTER
STICK IN LIFE BUT WE AREN'T
COMPLAINING.
WOMEN NEED A NATIONAL STRATEGY
TO FIX SOMETHING COMPARED TO THE
ISSUES THAT BOTH GENDERS FACE
RIGHT NOW UNDER JOE.
IT'S LIKE A DOCTOR GIVING THE
PATIENT FOR DIABETES TREATMENT
FOR HIS DANDRUFF.
IT'S THE SAME OLD STICK AS AS
THEY IGNORE ISSUES THAT ALL OF
US, CRIME, ECONOMY, EDUCATION,
FLATULENCE ON PLANES, CAT, THEY
CHASE THE STUFF THAT HELPS NO
ONE BUT THE DIVERSITY
CONSULTANTS.
IT'S EASY TO DO AND LIKE
MAYOR PETE, YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO
ANY WORK.
TELLING THE WORLD WE ARE ALL
SEXIST AND BIGOTS IS FREE, IT'S
THE ONLY THE PLAN THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE THAT ACTUALLY DOES COST
NOTHING.
BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS IS THE
CRAZY LADY THAT CACKLES I GOT
WHICH IN A HALLOWEEN HOUSE, THEY
BOTH WROTE A LETTER TOGETHER.
SHE HELD THE PEN.
CLAIMING THAT RATES OF
GENDER-BASED VIOLENCE HAVE RISEN
SIGNIFICANTLY.
REALLY, IS THAT SO?
MAY BE IT'S SO ALL VIOLENCE HAS
RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY.
THEY ONLY ADMIT THAT VIOLENCE
HAS GONE UP IF THEY CAN CHERRY
PICK THE VICTIMS.
GENDER-BASED VIOLENCE WENT UP
WITH ALL KINDS OF VIOLENCE, A
RISING TIDE OF BLOOD LIFTS ALL
CORPSES.
AT LEAST WE'VE HEARD FROM
KAMALA.
SHE DISAPPEARS MORE OFTEN THAN
JESSE WATTERS WHOM THE DINNER
BILL COMES.
YEAH, HE'S CHEAP.
THE TURMOIL WE SEE, CRIME,
OVERDOSE, MENTAL ILLNESS,
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN
LOUDOUN COUNTY, THEY PRETEND
NONE OF THIS EXISTS BUT THEY
HAVE PROBLEMS THEY EMBRACE, WHY
IS THAT?
LETS ASK OUR ANGRY WHITE MALE.
♪ ♪
>> WOW, I HAD NO IDEA MEN WERE
IN SUCH TROUBLE.
WE ARE GRADUATING LESS, EARNING
LESS MONEY, AND DYING AT FASTER
RATES.
I GUESS ON THE POSITIVE SIDE,
THAT WE HAVE A GOOD EXCUSE FOR
ALL THE HEAVY DRINKING TWO
CHEERS, GUYS.
>> Greg: THAT MAKES SENSE.
OUR COUNTRY RAMBLES DOWN AN
UNCERTAIN PATH LIKE A
"MY LITTLE PONY" COLLECTION,
IT'S WEIRD AND A LITTLE SCARY.
WE HAVE LEADERS WHO DENY WHAT WE
SEE WITH OUR OWN EYES AND IF WE
DON'T JOIN THEIR PHANTOM CRUSADE
WE ARE CALLED A RACIST OR SEXIST
OR EVEN WORSE, TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S.
THEY'VE EXPANDED THE MEANING OF
WHITE SUPREMACIST SO MUCH THAT
IT EVEN INCLUDES BLACK MODERATES
AND THEY WILL KILL ME IN THE
BATHROOM IF YOU DISAGREE AND NOT
FOR NORMAL REASONS.
WE ARE IN TOUGH TIMES BUT THE
ONLY JOBS DEMOCRATS CREATE ARE
IN DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
DEPARTMENTS THAT DIVIDE AND
EXCLUDE, WEIRD.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO STOP THEM
BUT THEY ARE ALL FLYING TO
ANOTHER GLOBAL WARMING SUMMIT IN
SCOTLAND.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
HE'S SO CONSERVATIVE, HIS KIDS
NAME ARE LIFE, LIBERTY, AND
LEMON.
MATT SCHLAPP!
YOU'LL BELIEVE HIS COMEDY IS
SUBJECTIVE ONCE YOU BEEN
SUBJECTED TO HIS COMEDY.
SHE CARVES UP PUMPKINS LIKE
EX-BOYFRIENDS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, CAT TIM PICKEL
PAUL BUNYAN IS DROPPING OFF WITH
HIM FOR HALLOWEEN.
YOU ARE STILL A WOMAN, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> AS A MALE TALK SHOW HOST
TALKING ABOUT THIS TOPIC I READ
THE REGULATIONS AND IT SAYS I
SHOULD GO TO YOU FIRST.
ARE YOU OBSESSED WITH GENDER
INEQUALITY?
>> NO, BUT YOU MISSED SOMETHING.
WOMEN LIVE LONGER, BUT THEY ALSO
AGE FASTER.
LIKE IN THE EYES OF SOCIETY.
AS YOU KNOW, IT IS MY BIRTHDAY
WEEK.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I WAS BORN!
IT'S MY BIRTHDAY WEEK, I'M
TURNING 33.
A 33-YEAR-OLD, IT'S NOT THE SAME
AS A MAN TURNING 33.
8:30 3-YEAR-OLD MAN IS A YOUNG
GUY WITH HIS LIFE AHEAD OF HIM.
TURNING 33 AS A WOMAN, PEOPLE
ARE ALREADY SAYING STUFF TO ME
LIKE YOU LOOK GREAT FOR YOUR
AGE.
IT'S NOT A COMPLEMENT TO.
HIM >> Greg: IT ISN'T.
>> IT'S SAYING YOU LOOK A LOT
LESS CLOSE TO DEATH THAN YOU
ACTUALLY ARE.
TELL ME I LOOK LIKE [BLEEP] IT'S
A LOT NICER.
THERE ARE WORSE THINGS ABOUT
BEING A WOMAN, I DON'T HATE MEN.
>> Greg: THANK GOD FOR THAT.
THAT'S A LOW BAR.
MATT, WELCOME TO THE SHOW, DO
YOU THINK THIS IS A DISTRACTION
ON PURPOSE OR DO THEY BELIEVE
THIS IS THE RELEVANT URGENT
MATTER THEY HAVE TO GO AFTER
RIGHT NOW?
>> YOU SEE ALL THESE BASIC
PROBLEMS PEOPLE HAVE AND THEY
HAVE BEEN HELPING PEOPLE AROUND
THE GLOBE, I GUESS THEY'RE GOING
TO CREATE KIND OF AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD AMONGST THE
GENDERS WHICH THEY DON'T EVEN
BELIEVE IN BY MAKING SURE THAT
MEN KEEP DYING OF COVID BY
KEEPING TONY FAUCI IN CHARGE OF
THE WHOLE THING.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THOSE STATS UNTIL I LOOKED THEM
UP THIS MORNING.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE SLIGHTLY,
MAYBE THERE'S A 3% -- 50%
GLOBALLY?
THAT SEEMS TO ME, JOE, LIKE A
PRETTY BIG STORY THAT SOMEBODY
LIKE YOU IN A TASTEFUL BEARD
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN.
>> A LOT OF IT IS BECAUSE MEN
DON'T COMPLAIN ABOUT THESE
THINGS AND I'M TRYING TO CHANGE
THAT BY COMPLAINING CONSTANTLY
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
>> IT'S SCARY TO SEE THIS IS THE
KIND OF DISTRACTION, OF COURSE
THEY ARE CREATING A DISTRACTION,
PETE BUTTIGIEG DIDN'T GO TO WORK
TOO MUCH, HE WAS HOME
BREASTFEEDING AND NO ONE NOTICED
HE WAS GONE.
I LOOK AT THAT LIKE THAT SHOWS
YOU NOT ONLY IS HE NOT UP TO THE
JOB, HIS JOB MIGHT NOT BE THAT
IMPORTANT.
IF MY SUPER PUTS UP A SIGN THAT
SAYS BACK IN 5 MINUTES THE
ENTIRE APARTMENT BUILDING
COLLAPSES.
HE'S A GUY WHO KNOWS HOW TO DO
THINGS.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO
DO ANYTHING AND SOMEHOW THEY ARE
IN CHARGE, IT'S REALLY, REALLY
SCARY.
>> Greg: IT'S SCARY BECAUSE OF
THE 10% OF THE DAY THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING, EVEN
WORKING 10% IS DESTRUCTIVE.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE THEM DO
NOTHING.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE
FLYING TO SCOTLAND FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE, THEY ARE SENDING SO MANY
PEOPLE TO SCOTLAND, IT'S
AMAZING, THE NUMBERS.
TO GET OUT OF THE UNITED STATES,
I GUESS.
TYRUS, WHERE DO YOU SIT ON THIS
ISSUE?
>> I SIT WHEREVER I WANT TO.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THIS STAT
UP BECAUSE MEN, WE HAVE TO START
BEING MORE EQUAL.
I'M SERIOUS, BECAUSE THESE
DEATHS ARE EXACTLY THE REASON
WHY THE NEXT TIME YOU HEAR A
SOUND DOWNSTAIRS, HONEY, YOUR
TURN.
MEN HAVE BEEN CONVINCED, WHO
RUNS INTO THE FIRE TO SAVE THE
BABY?
THE GUY.
WHO BREAKS IN THE HOUSE?
TOBIT IS OUT THERE, BUT I REALLY
WANT MY ICE CREAM, WHO GOES TO
GET IT?
THE GUY.
OF COURSE WE GET KILLED MORE
BECAUSE WE GET TALKED INTO STUFF
AND IF WE QUESTION IT, THEY ARE
LIKE REALLY?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE A REAL MAN.
AND WE FALL FOR THIS ALL THE
TIME.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY, FELLAS,
LET'S START SHARING THE WEALTH.
NEXT TIME WE HEAR A LOUD VOICE
IN MY HOUSE, I'M LIKE YOU'RE UP
DEAR.
IN PETE BUTTIGIEG 'S DEFENSE, IT
TAKES ABOUT TWO MONTHS TO GET A
PUMP ON A MAN, HAVE SOME DECORUM
AND RESPECT.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU OWE HIM
AN APOLOGY.
HIM >> I THINK TYRUS MAKES A
GOOD POINT, THAT'S WHY THERE'S
NO FEMALE VERSION OF WHEN PEOPLE
SAY MAN UP.
>> WOMEN ARE TOO SMART.
>> I DON'T DO ANYTHING, I DON'T
EVEN CLEAN.
>> Greg: I FEEL WE ARE IN
DANGER OF TURNING THIS INTO